thank you for coming to the um the
meeting of the cabinet on the 4th of
September
um the agenda the first item on the
agenda is apologies for absence and we
have apologies from
councilor calls counselor calls and
thank you very much there's no other
um apologies disclosures of Interest
we're reminded of the need to declare
any disclosures of Interest
beforehand we we already have on the
website uh particular things but if
there's any about anything that comes up
please make us aware during the meeting
the minutes now we have to confirm and
sign the minutes of the meeting that was
held on the 3rd of July do I have
anybody that wants to raise anything and
if not then we can I need somebody just
to say that they agree with the minutes
anything any anything that raised can I
just then say that we've confirmed the
minutes okay
agreed everybody
so the first item that we that we now
have referred to council is um the from
the planning and economic development
portfolio is the statement of community
involvement update and this is to
consider the revised version of
Stratford and Evans District Council
statement of community involvement for
public consultation and before we kind
of go into debate I don't know whether
the portfolio holder wants to say
anything but also we have this was
discussed at the overview and scrutiny
committee so if the ovarian scrutiny
committee chair wants to say anything on
this particular item
um please do
uh very brief on this one might not be
the same for other items but um yeah we
thought this this was a a thing that was
normally done early in the process
um no real comments and in it my sense
as well so yeah happy to endorse that
one and uh and our cancer coaches got
away lightly on this one other members
that becoming it might not get away so
lightly with the with scrutinized and
other items but uh yeah happy to have it
on from my own s
I'm Council culture do you want to say
anything or do you want to move the um
uh I mean just to say that I think uh
clear this is a tidying up exercise
um because we're now post covid and we
need to make sure that these statement
is really up to date and that's what it
is
um I'm proposing that it goes out to
consultation that will give Parish
councils if they so wish to make
representations to us about time scales
on planning applications I know
um certain Parish councils are exercised
about this
um but uh will be interested in having
their comments I think as part of the
consultation process
are we all agreed that um to accept
those the recommendation for that um
that policy paper okay
happy with that agreed thank you
the next item is the Stratford 1A Avon
Local Nature Reserve this is this is my
area and this is a recommendation
to agree to designating the Lynch
Meadows as a stratford-uponave and local
nature reserve and
um
I think it's fairly straightforward but
unless anybody has anybody got any
particular questions to ask of that one
and I think did this one come up with
overview and scrutiny
can't multitask miss the Books open like
that
um yeah we we had a discussion on this
and the deputy chief executive gave her
an overview on the sides of the project
and updated at the current slide
um
we found
um there were some parts of the report
there was lots of initials and Etc and
sometimes when you Bo and BNG actual 2s
h-o-t-s-st-t
um
and you have to read this carefully uh
the actual the actual report itself
um what we did feel that the
biodiversity net gain credits that
needed to be managed properly there
needs to be some processes put in place
to decide how the BNG credits were going
to be spent uh would be some spent to
get some um
sold how would they be sold would they
be sold for the county would they be
sold partially and would they be done
over a period of time because you'll
probably need some money to pump Prime
the project to start off with
um and again we would need to understand
that process and we don't want it to
become unrealty like the section 106 and
so on one is that sometimes you're
chasing detail to see where that money
has gone so I think that's important
there was lessons learned about the the
challenges of working with the various
contractors and meeting environmental
regulations
and I think it was fair to say that some
contractors perform better than others
during the work and strong contract
management was needed at times so again
I think that's something to learn from
about a strong contact management
and we felt that the projects are going
back to awareness in 12 to 18 months
time to see how things have progressed
uh particularly around the processes
around biodiversity in that game
and the members also wanted to make
known uh to Craig born
um the environmental enablement service
manager for his good work particularly
around the Fountain of wildflowers along
the river instructors arriving so
um
it's really good to buy lots of things
talked about and some learning points
and also some clarification in the
future and for it to come back to our
own s in 12 title month style which we
think's very reasonable
thank you that that is usual the one of
the items that you picked up is in the
paper and it's about the the gap between
liabilities from a maintenance and the
receipt of BNG money uh there it is
suggested that there will be a temporary
provision of 20 000 may have made
available for 12 months which will be
repaid when the first
um biodiversity net gain credits are
sold so that's the kind of trying to
make sure that that is done the the item
um is about making sure that it is
properly
maintained and that will be done by an
external consultant not yet in place but
that is to be done and that there will
be a a trust a partnership between the
Stratford Town trust and that external
consultant to form the management board
and that will be the board will oversee
the ecological management and the
grounds maintenance of the site and then
there will be the biodiversity net gain
will make sure that there is finance
coming in to cover the ongoing costs
going forward so I take your point that
it would be useful to have a review uh
exactly after the 12 months
um so I'm sure that could be arranged
yeah
we found
um the result of 12 18 months and
perhaps some members of the board would
come back to our own S as well to
discuss their views as well so I think
it's
we do that with other organizations
other partners so we just thought that
you know I meant to say that would be
the other part of the osc return so
thank you I I think this is quite a key
thing in that we do need to now that
we've got to a certain point we have to
make sure that the land is properly
managed going forward is has anybody
else got any comments that they want to
make on this particular item because at
the moment we have a recommendation
which says that we will go forward to to
seek the designation of the Lynch
Meadows as a local nature reserve and
that the certain steps will be taken
then to make sure that the subsequent
ecological management of the site is
enabled and then the recommendation is
for the external consultant coordinate
to the working partnership with the town
trust and that external consultant to
form the management board and then the
site to be registered at biodiversity
net gain site to allow the ongoing
ecological management of the site funded
through those BNG developer
contributions and are taken on board
what has been
suggested by the overview and scrutiny
committee chair that we look at it and
review it in about 12 months time
I will formally move that recommendation
as the portfolio holder responsible is
that anybody that would like to second
that
um Lorraine grococott who is the
portfolio holder that covers the
environmental in it it's a Leisure area
so thank you very much indeed now we've
got to go to vote does is everybody
agreed with the
um the recommendations that have been
put forward to you are you happy to
progress with that designations seeking
that designation okay agreed thank you
the next item is the performance
monitoring report for the quarter one
and that is also comes under my
portfolio
and this one is to a report to the
cabinet on the position of the Court one
performance monitoring report
2023-24 and any issues to identify for
further consideration to be addressed by
a further report to the cabinet and to
the portfolio holder
and it it goes through and picks out
those areas that have been achieved and
those that have not been achieved with
identifying areas on which to address it
and seek progress
does anybody have any particular
questions that they want to ask Sarah
Wally Huggins
uh thank you
um councilor junid
um I would like to ask really that there
are several decisions that were due to
be made by the 4th of September at this
meeting that includes the adoption of
countrywide private sector housing
assistance policy The Venture House
business center older people's
engagement report the Stratford
Riverside local nature reserve the
Gateway project and the part self and
custom build register all of these were
due for decisions in the 4th of
September and I'm merely inquiring as to
why that is not in today's papers or
that any decision has been made I
acknowledge the fact that some of these
have been bumped to the next uh Council
cabinet meeting but I see clarity as to
why that is and why you have been unable
to make a timely decision as in previous
reports thank you
um the the answer to that one is that
there has been an alteration in the
administration of this Council and
several of those items have had to take
a quite considerable questioning as to
where the previous one uh previous
position was for example on the Gateway
project we found out that there has been
a delay it's been in under consideration
now for 12 years uh and as a result
we've had to seek a particular
consultation with particular people to
make sure that we are inappropriate in a
process of being able to move forward on
that one
um why we had to understand why it has
it has been on the cars for 12 years and
with no progress being made I did have a
meeting with the chief executive of the
West Midland combined Authority I've had
other meetings with other people with
interests in that particular site to
understand why the problem what the
problems were so uh that's it has been
the Takeover that has laid that and some
of the other ones also we've had to seek
other information and other uh things
again they were left over from the
previous administration we've had to ask
questions of that and that's one of the
reasons why that is further delayed but
if anybody else has any other
um things that they want to add to those
George count to count
yes I mean at least two of those items
come within my portfolio area we are
radically changing policy in those areas
and it takes time to do that
um because frankly we need to improve on
our performance
um and uh frankly the Legacy that's been
left to us is not is not very very good
one
so we do now
thank you
um I think it was also agreed
um at the cabinet Forum that we will be
getting these quarterly reports rather
than six monthly which I think would
enable us to progress to monitor the
progress against the targets and kpis
more effectively than previously
yes indeed that has been agreed
chairman of avian scrutiny
thank you Council unit yeah we we talked
briefly well really briefly it um I wear
some on Friday
um I think one areas that's recorded
most was targets of communications and I
believe that the deputy chief exec uh
combined and confirmed that about three
months it was a realistic Target to see
improvements in the area
um I think there are potentially
resource implications regarding
Communications and how we do these
things as well
um
I think
[Music]
um
won the point to discuss was the view
um that
um and no alternative to to producing
the view in in terms of regional
residence and obviously Clinton 60k
magazines wasn't a sensible option from
an environmental point of view but it
still appreciated that some members of
the community still needed a paper
version
um and I think we should be taking
advice from Partners such as faster age
concern how we best reach those people
who need that in the most cost effective
and efficient way so
um so I think there's got to be some
some discussion about that and I think
I'll be talking a bit later about
um the website as well so and that's
linked it linked to partly as well in
terms of communication
although chief executive would like to
come in and then I'll secure counselor
Wally Huggins to come in afterwards
think thank you later
um just just to confirm the comments in
relation to the communications issues
they are behind that that falls to me
that they've been my particular work
areas
I'm not sure how much members are aware
but we have been very under resourced in
in PR over the last few months that
position is improving and we do have a
new starter who's going to be joining
the authority next week to help us with
some of the issues that we've been
facing the issue of the view magazine is
a point well made we have been
historically been producing the view at
a very low cost to the council
um I don't want to say it's such a low
cost that the publisher has gone bust
but the person that we have been working
with is no longer in business we've been
talking to other local authorities about
options which Haven for instance would
produce a similar publication their
publication is about five times the cost
of that Stratford at the moment so that
would have to be picked up in the budget
process but um the points I recognize
the points and the the the targets
haven't been met and that's for me to to
do better on those areas
and councilman against
just come back to counselor character
actually there is quite a lot of
slippage here councilor culture and uh
this is clear evidence to us that this
Administration has failed to get a grip
on very meaty matters you've been in
power for well over 100 days now and
it's very clear evidence to me that the
liberal Democrats were very ill-prepared
for leadership and the decision-making
processes that were required and the
workload that you are currently facing
thank you
and counselor Wally Huggins I used to be
in that position that was never the
language that I ever allowed myself to
use because I I am a professional and I
believe in making sure that we all work
together on this thank you very much
now it's I have a recommendation to move
uh and the the recommendation is that
the position in relation to the quarter
one performance monitoring report
2023-24 is received and any issues
identified for further consideration be
addressed by a further report to the
cabinet and that has been agreed and to
the portfolio holder and that has been
agreed do I agree to the whole paper as
um
yeah
um and I need a second I'm sorry a
reminder that I do need a second uh
George counselor cancer now moving to
the rest of the cabinet are you agreed
that that is to be accepted
thank you very much indeed
moving on to the next one which is
um the performance the notice of motion
capitalizing on Military talent and I
think
that comes
under myself as well
um one one of the things that we found
when we were looking at the noted
emotion was that the district council
has already signed the Covenant signed
it in 2012 however what the council did
not do was
seek accreditation under that Covenant
and there is accreditation accreditation
available
um there's either bronze or silver or
gold and I say which had been signed in
2012 there had been a member an officer
Champion but there'd never been a member
Champion despite the signature so this
is now trying to move that further
further on
um to select an option and from the
notice of motion into
0.1.1 you will see
um that there is a proposal to adopt an
officer armed
um they to adopt a member Covenant
champion and that will be counselor
Skinner and to recommend to the
employment committee that the counselor
applies for the Bronze award under the
defense employers recognition schemes
and considers the requirements for the
silver award so that is the one that I
would seek to move uh I think after
um you know having signed the Covenant
in 2012 we do need to move on and and uh
and do something with that um with that
Covenant uh so that is the the option
that I'm moving and would seek uh
approval on councilor
Rock
just a word of explanation in I believe
counselor skin is a member of the
reserve reserved Armed Forces is he not
he is indeed he's a reservist uh and
there is already an officer champion and
that is uh Paul Reed so we would then
have completed the requirements from the
under under the the com the recognition
scheme anybody else that want to
counselor Wally huggy
thank you um the conservatives are
delighted that the conservative motion
that was put on put forward
um is is coming to the fore here and I'd
also like to put on notice that um we
are of course relieved and delighted
there's an off uh that um an officer of
Paul Reed's caliber is the um appointed
council's representative or the Armed
Forces Champion as his attendance and
training record is of course exemplary
along with his extensive and outstanding
military record we are lucky indeed to
have Paul Reed as a representative for
this very important group of people
thank you
and since we had signed in 2012 we now
actually have to do something with it
it's been 12 years 11 years sorry with
nothing done with it so now we move on
and that the we will take it to the
employment committee to seek bronze or
silver accreditation according to
um the
um the defense employer recognition
scheme and by completing a member
position uh we will again have submitted
and recognized the the full seriousness
and the value of this to to the district
council it completes the uh that what
was already signed so thank you for
drawing it to our attention that you
know that had had been signed in 2012 we
hadn't realized that and now we can do
something with it so I'm the
recommendation is that the council the
cabinet selection option I have moved
the option
um on in 2.1.1 which is to appoint the
officer the as a member to appoint a
counselor as a member and to seek
recommendation to the employment
committee for the bronze or silver award
do we have anybody else that wants to
make a comment and if so please do
councilor Rock
German noting what the leaders
opposition has said about the uh the
member as the staff representative does
that need to be answered his question
for does that need to be alluded to in
any way in the motion or that's all
that's already has been in place for
some time I believe isn't it but
although I actually would concur with
everything she said about that so I'm
happy to second the motion the chairman
are there any any other Comics No in
which case I've moved him the uh
recommendation uh councilor Rock has
seconded a recommendation are we
approving it agreed
agreed thank you
moving on to the concessionary parking
permit
yeah I think we had a group dispensation
last time I don't know whether we need
to declare or I need to declare a
potential interest in this uh uh item
chairman I I if I could just summarize
for the benefit of our new management
officer who wasn't in the room last time
um it's possible probable dare I say
that a number of members in the room may
be covered or affected by this
particular issue however given the
number that may be affected the previous
monitors officer got into the
dispensation under the circumstances to
allow for the proper debate of the item
and and just I guess seeking the same
kind of um
officer thank you
chair just to confirm I am happy with
the dispensation and the circumstances
um having looked at the Constitution it
is within my remit to allow for
dispensation in circumstances such as
these
and just to be clear I I don't have a
pimp permit but I am of an age where I
could seek a permit so therefore just
making it quite clear
um so we also have had uh and I will
bring in the portfolio holder in a
moment but I believe that we've had an
email that has been circulated around as
well just on that point I the one point
that was raised in that email was about
alternative schemes such as small bus
scheme and whether that's been
considered I just want to make it clear
that I've already set up and it was set
up somewhere to go a meeting with the
County Council
um who are responsible for public
transport about public transport for not
only the town but for the whole of the
area and to try to explore further not
only how and why we don't have a as good
a public transport as we could have but
also how to improve it given the timing
of the local local plan I thought it was
a good time to be able to explore
further about public transport and
because the County Council has also done
their local transport plan number four I
think it is which is a strategic plan so
we are having that discussion
councilor gocom
thank you leader um
just as a point do I need to answer
these questions in the um in this before
I progress with the motion
so to be clear we've received an email
from councilor Bromwich which has got
five points um in relation to the
introduction of the conceptionally
passing you can either respond now or
Council bombage outside but possibly a
brief response in relation to the points
I just before I didn't know it before
and perhaps um perhaps also you could
acknowledge that you will get back to
him with more detailed information if
it's available to him later stage
so thank you leader thank you exactly
see so um for the letter that's received
from councilor Bromwich his first point
is about the final Financial impact
figures
um actually in the report section 5.2
does answer this
um these uh these issues that he's
raised so I'd like to
um direct out your attention to them so
there will be Administration enforcement
costs and our offices have are satisfied
that the 50 pounds will cover these
charges
um
so with the second
um any shortfall where how will it be
made up well I mean it's not going to be
possible to quantify at this stage I
mean the um the pensioner car park was
formally
um
withdrawn in 2021
um and without any sort of contemplation
of how exactly how much revenue was
going to generate for the uh the
administration then so and at that time
I mean there was the budget for 22 21-22
there was actually a loss on um you know
lower 500 000 pound lower than before
which we can't really quantify was at
least people coming or was there
anything to do with the counselor you
know with the pensioner parking scheme
these things are you know we cannot
quantify them and actually the
introduction of an PR will allow us to
be get the data to be able to know
exactly how much this scheme is
potentially costing us or making us
um so for question three
contemplate the scheme
um
we're talking about the residence local
to Stratford itself I mean this was a
Manifesto uh pledge from us in the
liberal Democrats damianifesto we are
being we've been put powered to deliver
on those and this is what we are doing
at the moment so I'm sure my colleagues
will want us to forward that and the
environmental impact again at this
present stage is not possible to
quantify but please be assured that
liberal Democrats the environment and
sustainable travel is very much forward
to our manifestos as well and as we can
see last week why should pensioners I've
got access to a um bus free bus pass be
actively going out the way to go into
their cars with the fact that we're our
transports may not be as reliable as
with the collapse of the green bus line
last week or with certain the reduction
in service from the green bin green bus
party last week you know it illustrates
that we do not have reliable public
transport this is something we would be
looking at as a regime so obviously on
that I will get back to um Council
Bromwich on any questions that I have
not answered fully thank you and
um we I have spoken to councilor
Bromwich myself and but also and
councilor Rock has been in touch and and
has spoken to him um emailed him with
information as well councilor of Wally
Huggins
yes our views on this concessionary
parking permit permit uh scheme are well
evidenced and we've been very vocal
about it however I will pay tribute to
the lib Dems because this is uh clearly
an example of how you make such uh the
breathtaking speed and decisive work
you're able to do with a gradual scheme
that wasn't even in the plan and I'm
wondering which element of a slippage to
the uh 4th of October
um is as a direct consequence of the
rapid and breathtaking speed of the
concessionary parking permit scheme
coming forward being brought forward by
you
um just to also let you know that the
conservatives will be looking at the a
take up and location of those seeking
these permits with granular interest
um we will be seeking detailed uh
reports of who is taking up these
schemes
um and because let's summarize this this
was an election promise made by uh
a small group of your counselors and the
the speed with which this has been
brought forward and not thought about
carefully enough is is frankly very
disappointing thank you
it just had no impact on the rest of the
council but a forward planner at all
thank you very much indeed uh we now
have a recommendation to put to you that
following the completion of the osppo
um statutory consultation the con
stationary permit is implemented from
the 1st of October 2023. have we got a
mover for that recommendation
yes leader I'd like to move that
recommendation and have we got a
seconder
councilor guest
and are you all agreed to that
you agreed
agreed thank you very much indeed
moving on now to the um housing and
customer services portfolio and in the
absence of
um councilor calls um I am going to
address this one so I will introduce it
and move it and this is about
um the authorization of a payment in
order to
um of 750 000 from commuted sums to
progress the local Authority housing
funding program as detailed in the in
the report the funds will enable the
purchase of new build properties for
users affordable housing in order to
meet the needs of the refugee arrivals
most vulnerable to homelessness I.E
Ukrainian and Afghanistan households
having
um
partnered with platform Housing
Association there's only excuse me
um there's only a limited pool of new
build Market properties across the
district to meet this need and therefore
to allow prompt offers to developers
platform requires timely decisions from
the council in order to make a quick
decision and realistic offer when
competing in the marketplace and then
the recommendation therefore requests
the authorization of that payment of up
to 750 000 from commuted sums to
progress the local Authority housing
fund program as detailed in this report
this will be delegated to the deputy
chiefing executive in consultation with
the portfolio holder monitoring officer
and section 151 officer do I have any
questions on this one and if not I will
certainly move it councilor Huggins it
isn't a question it is a comment and we
welcome this initiative and I heartened
that the deputy chief executive uh will
have the authority to do this thank you
are there any questions particular about
it does the chief executive or deputy
chief executive need to say anything it
is
um make to make something happen that it
desperately needs to happen and it's
something that I would welcome so I'm
going to move that recommendation do we
have anybody that will be seconding that
that recommendation
Curtis both of you either of you
okay now then do we agree it
agreed thank you very much indeed that's
approved and thank you very much on that
one
and then moving forward which is um
these are being taken together and
counselor capture will be the portfolio
holder on this one but it's about the
notice of motions in respect of the
provision of community Public Access
defibrillators on new developments the
impact of solar farm developments and
public houses counselor capture
thanks very much indeed share
um always surprising I think that we get
no submotion asking for new facilities
at the start of a new um a new
Administration when frankly we could
have asked for a new
defibrillators many many years ago and
clearly
um this Council as all councils are
under great pressure by this government
and we do not have money to just do just
to uh to add to services without seeing
exactly where that income will come from
so clearly if we want to do more
defibrillators the money is going to
have to come from 106 agreements and we
are left a legacy here already as a
council from previous decisions by made
by previous Council that we have
underfunded many of our developments in
our area and and this is just going to
put more pressure on it but if we're
going to fund defibrillators for the
future and we accept that we can put
that and within that it'll have to be a
matter for consideration
by planning decisions either by
condition or by 106 agreements I have to
say in my own Ward frankly I've got more
concerns about litter bins which
currently we don't have any provision
for and I know Council Grove Court is
taking up my issues
um on on that on that behalf but it is
pressure that we're having to put on on
106 agreements so that's our
recommendation is that
um John careford and his team will
negotiate
um the provision of money for
defibrillators as part of the overall
package in relation to 106 agreements
in relation to solar energy and clearly
we are under considerable pressure to
provide more sites for solar energy and
we I think are very much in favor of a
sustainable energy and therefore looking
uh positively at that but we are also
very concerned that we are protecting
our highest grade agricultural land in
South Warwickshire and our policy which
will obviously be being embedded in the
new local plan and will ensure that
these are not provided on grade one
grade two and grade 3 a
um agricultural land because we believe
that protecting Food Supplies are also
extremely important
um for the future to to
um so clearly that's a matter for
further consideration as we prepare the
South Warwickshire local plan
third matter in relation to public
houses
um is an issue in many villages indeed
and it is of great local concern we are
aware of a number of of public houses
that have been closed
um in in recent times and we're
proposing that we actually set up a task
and finish group in relation to this
this admin will be very much supportive
of those communities that want to set up
Community interest companies because
that is one way that we have got
um already preserved some some notable
public houses in our district and we
hope that we can help communities do
that going forward but that will be a
matter for the task and finish group
when it's set up
thank you very much from that one and
before I bring councilor rocking I have
a public house in my area that we've now
got
um the the application in for
um to rebuild but it's been 28 months
since a fire took place in there I would
be very very interested in making sure
that when it is rebuilt it is retained
as a public house so that is something
that I I would negotiate and talk to the
task and finish group about uh should
that ever arise that it does not become
a party remain as a public house uh
councilor rock thank you chairman in
respect of recommendation one the first
thing to say is I've been on the
receiving end of a defibrillator
so um I think that constitutes an
interest I previously declare
um and and secondly uh just to note I I
I think
the it's worth saying I think once again
it's the maintenance of these things
they're not expensive to provide but uh
I I think the point is it's keeping them
going so when when these are being
negotiated by officers I think it's
worth officers noting that we need some
maintenance in perpetuity to be
considered in a 106 agreement or
condition however we do it thank you
chairman
councilor capture are you formally
moving those recommendations yes chair I
am and do we have a seconder for those
recommendations councilor gocott thank
you very much do go to the vote
Council of Wally Huggins she wanted to
come in
yes I just wanted to place on record at
councilor rock that we're very grateful
indeed for the defibrillators all right
we're all everybody was very concerned
about you and we're very glad that they
had the desired effect in demonstrating
quite so wonderfully of how important
they are so so thank you and I also uh
wanted to say that um
in respect to the of the public houses
how heartened I am that clearly this is
um
transcends everything within the
Stratford District they all need to be
mindful of this and I know that uh Louis
Adams the chair of the planning
committee is also Keen for for for this
work I've circulated a lot of work
that's already been done with other
authorities
um on on on this on this matter so I am
glad and heartened that it's going to uh
that a task and finish group is going to
be established uh on this but can I just
also point out uh that I can't um see
any reference
um uh regarding the cabinet papers or on
the agenda as to who it was that brought
these matters
um to the attention that brought these
Notions of motives most the notes on
motion we had the capitalizing military
Talent the the councilors were named
there and also the impatience review the
councils have been named there but we
have not had the councilors mentioned in
item 10 uh and either the cabinet papers
here or on the agenda and I would like
that to be amended please to reflect
that thank you I understand the chairman
to come in at that point
yeah it's just the brief points um the
first one the impact of solar farm
development of sales chair planning
committee for a while and I agree the
point about
protect
agricultural lands that obviously for
food production and we did one two and
three a
I think we just need to make sure that
they are in the right categories because
we had to sow the farm application on
land was
um
class is 3A I think at the time and when
we spoke to the applicant there was
blight on the on the land they couldn't
use it for what they were going to be
doing and
um
some of the supplies that we've been
used to make ethanol so I think we just
need to be pragmatic and make sure that
the classification is is correct so we
we have a fine balance on that one and
the other bit about defibrations yeah
totally agree
um but my other hat on County on funding
two part funding two defibrillators or
upgrades one in Upton which is Nova
hopefully help counselor up just in case
and one in one in save them at the
Cricket Club on Treasure of and um
and if anybody is actually in safe I'm
on the 29th of September I will be doing
the quiz at the Cricket Club to help
raise funds for different varieties as
well so thank you for uh
I I have the chief executive wants to
come in at this point
thank you chairman the the point that
councilor Woody huggage makes absolutely
we will reflect that
um in the report to council because the
mission from my perspective all the
notifications emotions that we've got on
the agenda at the moment originated in
Council and there would be a
recommendation back to council so what
cabinet over green today is a response
to those notice emotions and when the
report goes back to Cabinet a big
Council will be clear who initiated the
uh the original notice emotions but I
I'm afraid I do need to change it so
it's not recommendation so you can
resolve upon is recommendations to
Council on all of those matters thank
you
so we've had the recommendations to
council moved um by councilor counter
and said uh
we can't really can't remember whether
we scored secondary councilor go cup
um so are we agreed on those items
agreed thank you very much indeed moving
forward then uh to the endorsement of
the Cotswold National Landscape
Management plan 2023 to 24.
and this one is
come to the counselor capture
um it's a very very good document I have
to say I'm very impressed by it
um and our recommendation is quite clear
that we should be taking it into account
in the preparation of our local plan
neighborhood plans and our strategy
strategies policies and projects and it
should become a material consideration
and when considering applications
certainly within the the within the area
of outstanding natural beauty
um but also in adjoining areas as well
so I would move the recommendation chair
to second that councilor councilor Wally
hogings I do know that you have
um you are involved in this at some in
your area I am the um elected member who
is the representative on this on this um
and I spoke to Nigel Rock about this at
the start of this uh the new era and I'm
grateful for that appointment and I'm
also grateful for this ringing
endorsements of this document because it
is meaty it is um it will help a lot in
in planning matters and um I I thank you
for that thank you
and I had a letter directly to myself
from the chief executive of the Cotswold
National Landscape Management
um organizing Cotswold conservation
board actually and um I need Now to
respond once that decision is taken so
I'm happy to do that so we've got the
recommendations before us uh it had they
have been moved I've been seconded are
they agreed
okay thank you very much
moving forward is the next item is the
future provision of shop Mobility
no sorry my organ I overlooked one item
which is the approval of procurement
Guest House Hotel framework for
discharge of homelessness duties and
powers and again in the absence of
councilor calls I will
um take this one on and the
recommendation we have here
are about public procurement and this is
about making sure that the process for
procuring temporary accommodation
service in order to discharge our
homelessness duties and powers are able
to go forward it's a service that's not
previously been procured and it's been
highlighted through the internal audit
scrutiny that it hadn't been procured in
the past so while the report is very
much about process it also advises of
the way in which the council manages the
homeless service details the challenges
and the opportunities that is presented
by procuring the service we can test
best value and whilst existing providers
will be expected to Tender we can test
the market in relation to any new
provision that we do not currently
access and through the delivery of a
framework agreement we'll have the
flexibility to access the right type of
accommodation in the right place to meet
the household's needs and at the right
price
and when in an exceptional circumstances
there's a need to re-house outside the
district the council can access the
calder's crown commercial service
framework agreement
the Constitution specifies that an
expenditure of above 150 000 is a key
decision however there is a specific
provision for procurement and where a
procurement has been approved in a
principle by the cabinet that's a key
decision and the subsequent decision to
award the contract is not a key decision
and can be made under dedicated
authority to the head of service in
consultation with the portfolio holder
in order to make a timely award so the
process for which approval is sought is
therefore fully encompassed within the
recommendations so I'm going to move
those recommendations do we have any
comments to make
um and anybody that is willing to second
that councilor Curtis
I think thank you leader just a very
brief comment that I'm pleased to see a
0.524 the financial implications are put
in a table which I did ask for at the
cabinet form and I think it does make it
much easier to read rather than the in
the just in the general narrative but um
I welcome that change thank you
anybody else want to make any comments
in which case the decision is to make
sure that this can move forward now and
the recommendation is granted to procure
hotels and guest houses within the
district onto the framework agreement uh
to for the purpose of fulfilling the
council's duties and exercising its
powers in respect of homelessness the
position that permission is given to
award the framework agreement based on
the evaluation of tenders for the
contract to award to be delegated to the
head of Housing and customer service in
consultation with the portfolio holder
and then where an exceptional
circumstances it's necessary to place
households Outside The District in
hotels and guest houses permission is
granted to seek the use of calder's
crown commercial service framework
agreement that's the full recommendation
I have moved it it has been seconded do
you agree to it
agreed thank you
we now move on to the Future provision
of shop mobility and again I'm going to
take this one in the absence of
councilor calls but I'm very honored to
take it on for another reason and that
is I was leader of the council
um 25 years ago and
um actually asked for shop Mobility to
proportion in the first place and I was
really honored at the time that it was
taken on board by officers and the shop
Mobility scheme what did come to
Stratford on even as a result
it's a valued service to the town so the
the
um but it is a service that we meet must
make sure
um survives and it goes forward to be
strengthened and become a key part of an
offer that this camp this town can give
to its residents but also to the
tourists that come to the town
it is something that I feel very
strongly about so I am recommending that
we go with the recommendation that is
that the operation of the shop Mobility
service be transferred to active
Mobility for an initial period of three
years and that the deputy chief
executive be authorized to negotiate all
final details required to implement this
decision and this is because I believe
that we must make sure that we have a
shop ability that goes on into the
future
um for many many years to come
I would like to play pay pay particular
thanks to a former officer Council David
officer David Platts who has stayed on
to make sure that this is um this was
negotiated I would like to place it on
record my thanks to him
but if anybody wants to have any
particular
details of it it's in the in the um in
the full papers uh and um I want to
raise this before we actually go to
debate I know this was raised at the
ovarian scrutiny so the chairman of
Alvin's group might want to come in yeah
very briefly on this cancer Journey
please um yeah we'll just concern about
the potential any potential impacts on
staff so I think we all need to keep an
eye on that but overall we were
satisfied with the opportunity to
transfer to the service to active
Mobility as a preferred option in terms
of continuing the service to a suitable
standard for our residents and also
potentially improve so
um it was full endorsement of this from
the unscrutiny and Council Sarah Wally
Hopkins
and I'd just like to endorse everything
that you said at Council unit because it
is a vital service that we provide
within the district thank you
I'd also like to place on record in
particular thanks to the Friends of the
shop Mobility charity who have kept this
going for so many years raised so much
money for to enable this to happen and
to carry on but also I'd like to raise
and thanks to
um to Elizabeth Dixon from accessible
Stratford who's also taking part in the
negotiations and made in making sure
that this um has has our future
it it is something I as I said I feel
strongly about so option C is the
transfer to transfer the operation of
the shop Mobility service to active
active Mobility for an initial period of
three years and this is to make sure
that there is a future
um for the service
there will be other things that we will
have to take on board as a result of of
the process but at the moment this is
the recommended a pure recommendation is
that the operation uh be transferred and
that that deputy chief executive be
authorized to negotiate all the final
details required to implement the
decision
I'm going to move that one
um Council account purchase uh thank you
leader um I just wanted to
um say that I also welcome the inclusion
of uh appendix 5 the equality impact
assessment
which clearly outlines and gives the it
gives further good evidence base
to the shop Mobility proposal and this
is something I think that I have
mentioned at the the equality impact
assessments can be used to provide
strong evidence base
demonstrating an increase in provision
so thank you very much for that it's a
very useful piece of evidence it's
online it wasn't included in the
original bundle but thank you I need a
seconder for that
for the recommendation Council against
and do we all agree
agreed thank you very much indeed
moving on to the inpatients review of
The Ellen Badger hospital and we do have
some people that from members of the
public who've asked to address the
cabinet and um so if I just kind of
introduce it again I'm covering for
counselor Coles
and the change
there is a change to the recommendation
that I will move and the change the
recommendation I will outline that first
and then we will have people come
forward to put their case
the changes recommended to
3.1.1 and the first paragraph I would
like to ask that the council resolves
for the leader and portfolio holder to
continue to in Brackets right to
Warwickshire County Council
Swift and the NHS Coventry and
Warwickshire integrated care board to
Raise This council's concerns preferred
policy as per above and that the council
supports the public consultation
exercise on the recommendations as
requested request by WCC
ascosc which is the acronym for the
I can't remember what the net what it
stands for but it is a long agreement
for the social care body that governs
adult social care and health overview
and scrutiny committee at the
Warwickshire County Council
so can those people a counselor
um
I've got John Denny as the one that's
put forward a request to address the
the cabinet
thank you chair counselors of three
minutes Council
good morning thank you for letting me
speak on behalf of rural South
Warwickshire residents we feel betrayed
by the intention to remove inpatient
beds from the Ellen badger shipston town
councils already written in support of
this this motion
but it's not just the town it's also all
the villages and all the country folk in
between
we deplore the delay granted by the ICB
and do not trust Swift to consult fairly
the badger has cared for our community
since 1896.
Ann Coyle's June 2021 vision
of a place-based Integrated Health Care
was exactly what the badger should be
primary secondary and Community Care all
co-located on one site
obtaining Mutual benefit from the
sharing of skills and development of
personnel and Facilities exactly as laid
out in the planning statement referred
to in the decision letter of the only
approved planning application from
yourselves
paragraph 319 of that statement says
there are no plans to take away beds
from the hospital
in September 21 the Department of Health
offer a funding to new hospitals closed
without any bid from Swift
because Mr Burley had already determined
that beds be moved from shipston to
Leamington Spa
we need a complete hospital with GPS
included
this car installs 1.4 million sill money
has not enabled the GPS to take part in
the project
45 percent of our population is over 55
the care sector
is and will be a major part of our
economy
in an integrated Badger Care workers can
be upskilled achieved professional
qualifications and provide enhanced care
Warwickshire adult Health overview and
scrutiny committee has twice rejected
the proposals requesting an increased
number of beds with enhanced services
and the public be adequately consulted
the ICB have called for proper
consultation but have allowed Swift a
nine months delay to prepare a business
case
the hospital has already been demolished
and something else is being built in its
place
we believe that Swift intend to complete
their building during this delay and
then cease building operations
public meetings marches and media
reporting have amply demonstrated we you
can the journey have had the three
minutes
John is there a just a wind-up
we consider that removing the badge from
the Badgers a grievous Beach of the
social contract
thank you that very much appreciated
does anybody have any questions before
Mr Denny moves from the his seat
in which case thank you very much indeed
I do appreciate that you've come forward
to give this published statement from
people in shipston thank you very much
indeed I also have two other people that
want to address one is councilor
passenger and then the other is
counselor put together and again the
three-minute rule no no three minute
rule for you two
you are privileged okay thank you very
much
addressed the uh the cabinet
oh
right
good morning everyone
um as John as just said shipsens had a
hospital the anime Badger hospital for
uh over 125 years
um it was endowed by Richard badger in
memory of his wife for the benefit of
the people of shipston and over many
years the people of ships and have
contributed to the hospital through the
friends of Ellen Badger hospital and
raised money for new equipment and and
other ways
um six years ago the South Warwickshire
NHS Foundation trust promised a brand
new hospital and but and for three years
everyone was very excited about this
Prospect three but three years ago they
published at the plans which included a
new hospital with award for beds and
included the doctor's surgery new
medical center a range of medical
services and a and a healthy wellbeing
Center
this was going to be part of our
fantastic new fully Integrated Health
Care system service
um based on this the friends of Alan
Badger Hospital donated 650 000 pounds
towards the hospital and the community
community reluctantly accepted that the
old hospital which had great sentimental
value for many people be pulled down
but then two years ago they told us that
the second phase of the building that
included the ward with beds was delayed
indefinitely and that there was they
were going to have a bed review
almost immediately they took the beds
away and took them to lemington
and the experience since then of local
people have been impatience at Warwick
Hospital and been waiting for Community
Care has been dire
frail and ill people are being sent home
within a few days uh having and then
after a few days having to call 999 and
be readmitted putting a tremendous
strain on the ambulance services people
being stuck in hospital bed blocking
with no home care package available
people packaged away to expensive care
homes on the other side of lemington for
weeks where it is difficult for family
and friends to visit
the removal of the beds has amounted to
a drastic reduction in the health care
service provision for the people of
shipston
and the surrounding area a service that
they have had for 125 years
at the Warwickshire County Council
overviews committee overview and
scrutiny Committee in February 2022
um the interim finding of the bed review
was given
and in response to this many County
councilors from all all over the county
and particularly from North Warwickshire
where they have no Community Hospitals
called for more Community Hospitals and
more beds
Swift have ignored this these calls
at the Warwickshire County Council
overview and scrutiny committee the
health overview and security Committee
in June of this year Glenn Burley
himself the chief executive of Swift
finally presented the the findings of
the bed review but astonishingly not the
full report which they have now refused
to issue after a freedom of information
request
there there have been several Promises
of Extra Care in the community which
um is completely improving well that it
will provide the same Services of a
community hospital does
we know that Community Hospitals work
there are 500 in this country
The Ellen Badger Hospital in shipston
worked for 125 years
we call on the cabinet to support the
retention of inpatient beds at the new
Ellen banter hospital please support the
motion
thank you very much indeed councilor
passing them and the next person who
wants to come in is counselor pertigella
and then I will call in
um councilor Wally Huggins and anybody
else that wants to come in after that
so um thank you councilor Junaid for
proposing the change inwarding to the
report's recommendations this reflects
the fact that between the 10th of July
when the motion was first submitted and
now the integrated cardboard started the
pre-consultation business case
indeed we ask the board that any public
consultation be as wide reaching as
possible and that its criteria and time
scale are communicated effectively it
has to be a 12-week consultation and
most importantly the fundings of the
public consultation must inform policy
decisions as we have heard the Lim
Badger hospital has provided care to the
town and surrounding Villages for
generations of residents and there is
considerable public upset over the
recommendation by South Worcester
University NHS Foundation trust that
inpatient beds should be relocated to
Leamington Spa following the bed review
this bed review has not been made public
yet a delay which is extremely
disappointing residents as well as tiers
of local government must have access to
the review which has informed the South
Warwickshire University NHS Foundation
trusts recommendation
Community Hospitals with impatient pets
provide important integrated Healthcare
facilities for the rural geographical
areas they occupy as well as employment
opportunities to the local community we
know community hospital beds enables
most patients to resume Independent
Living more quickly
this means that the loss of impatience
beds at the alembadger hospital will
only lead to Greater bed blocking of
acute beds and leading in turn to longer
stays in hospital than necessary
much of the rural population is made up
of an older demographic therefore the
provision of a comprehensive Healthcare
facility close to home is essential for
a rural elderly communities
the South Warwickshire University NHS
Foundation trust recommendations as they
stunt will have a disproportionate
impact on the provisional services in
our district
I hope that the cabinet of Stratford
District Council will be committed to
supporting the future of the alimbajo
hospital as a community hospital with an
impatient world and I look forward for
the motion coming back to full Council
thank you
councilor bully Hawkins
um thank you
sorry any questions first to can to
counselor but again any questions
anybody
in which case Council bully Huggins
my most important hats that I wear at
this Council really is that I am the
elected member for um South Warwickshire
which is brales and Compton and I know
that's the Ellen Badger hospital and the
current situation that we now find
ourselves in is is extremely important
so actually I'm going to endorse
anything that uh brings Glenn Burley and
the South Warwickshire NHS trust 2
account
um I understand that
um the
um ICB is coming to osc soon and you can
rest assured as I'm also on osc that
there will be proper scrutiny of all
aspects to do the Ellen Badger but I
just wanted to just to say
um that um
I endorse everything because it is a
very valued very valid and valued
hospital and my own sorry if I get
emotional my own grandparents many years
ago were benefited immensely from this
facility and it does it does matter to
so many people and will make a
difference in the centuries to come
however what I'm unsure about is what
officer time and which officers here are
going to be able to push this this this
forward on our on our residence behalf
and I do seek some clarity so that we're
all working smarter and harder together
in order to ensure that the residents
are served in the best possible way
thank you cancel the rock do you want to
come in at this point yeah thank you
very much in fact that last Point uh
that Sarah's just made is the one I
wanted to pick up because is it
I spent a lot of time working with a
Health Service in between being
counselors and otherwise
and it's a general question to officers
really which I think Sarah has just
proposed uh
in many arenas
is that the local Democratic influence
over the Health Service
seems to be in need of improvement
and I'm wondering I mean we can pass all
these motions and I soak in the scrutiny
committee at the county but it's it's a
very sort of elastic
control is too stronger a word elastic
influence we can have over it
um
it seems to me that the Democratic
control works via Parliament through the
local MPS
and that way now it was the case when I
was on the patient group
that when the law was changed
back 10 years ago and they were obliged
to capture the voice of the patient now
does anybody know whether that's working
and how does it work I'd just be
interested to know whether that is some
other mechanism that we can uh deal with
if there's a patient group that
influences it and I think we appoint
people do we not to the South we're
actually a board and is that is that is
there a mechanism there but I'm sure
that influence is limited
I've got the chief executive wants to
come in there at the moment and the also
the chair of the board we do get the
answer to that one
okay thank you chairman
the report actually on page 190
paragraph six which is legal
implications onwards identifies it in a
two-tier area
as as Stratford is the County Council
that has the formal Health scrutiny
powers and that's exercise through the
uh the very long adult social Care
Health overview and scrutiny committee
at the County Council
the notice of motion that was raised at
Council effectively was asking for two
things it was asking for
um there to be a consultation exercise
or for a support or write to the
adult social health and I've committee
asking the ICB to undertake a
consultation exercise that is happening
so there will be a consultation exercise
which is undertaken
we will have the opportunity as an
authority to respond to that
consultation exercise and it will be the
portfolio holder councilor Coles that
would do a portfolio holder decision in
relation to that so we we can make that
response
the nurses emotion also talked about a
referral to the Secretary of State
that that wouldn't be within our powers
that would have to be found if the
consultation exercise and it's
identified in paragraph 1.8 or 3.188 if
there are any concerns with the
consultation exercise itself then the
referral could be made to the Secretary
of State in relation to that process but
that would have to be done by again the
County Council we we have previously saw
from the County Council those Powers
because they could be delegated to The
District Council
and if members recall we sought that in
relation to the proposed changes to the
maternity unit at the the Horton
Hospital in Banbury that the County
Council decided that they wouldn't
delegate those powers and and whilst I
haven't asked a question in relation to
this particular ex issue I'd be very
surprised if they did delegate so the
primary lead would be the County Council
they would be the people who are
undertaking that review about the of the
consultation but we would
respond to the consultation exercise
itself
councilor Rock
yeah you've mentioned another word there
which I was I was going to ask our ships
and representatives uh had I thought
about it more quickly which is the the
influence of Horton on this because
Horton have had their own
shifts as to what they plan and and
ships them I just had to refresh my
memories how far it was from shipston to
Banbury but
um I'm sure there's been some influence
there as well and I hope the
consultation when they do it will will
take into account a sort of cross-border
effects because sometimes we think
there's a fence along the border
chairman for just picking up on that
particular appointment again
um you're right when it was the I think
it was the South walks of ccg
I think that was an acronym at the time
it was quite evident there hadn't been a
lot of cross-border dialogue with you
oh I think it was a shaving
Oxfordshire ccg at the time I hope that
his position has improved now with the
the creation of the south of which I
should be but we we have it as an
authority quite a number of of
cross-border issues the Horton Hospital
the Alex Hospital in in religion being
two of them as well but yeah as far as
recommendations go
they've had a change in the the proposed
recommendation which absolutely
recognizes the limitations that we have
as a local Authority that we can seek
consultation please think that
consultation is under being undertaken
we will participate in that and then if
we feel that the consultation has been
flawed we would have to make
representations send to the County
Council for them to make that any
referral to the Secretary of State
councilor Holly Huggins and then I just
was this an issue that was covered at
osc and do you want to go councilor
Trump
it was uh we were mentioned that it's
coming to ICB uh sorry the ICB are
coming to o s yeah
um and it would be an opportunity and
I'll try and circulate beforehand the
opportunity for councilors uh who do not
attend o and S one two attend if they
want to or to arrange questions or that
certified questions to me to raise at
the meeting
that I'm sure that would be very valued
and I'm sure that councilor put again
and councilor passing them will take
that on board that they do have the
opportunity to come to the osc I don't
know whether members of the public can
also come and raise issues but to please
clarify that with the counselor with Mr
dinny
um catch ceremony Huggins
it was just really to clarify for you
councilor rock that um when you are at
registered at shipston surgery then you
often get the choice of going to the
haunton hospital for treatment and vice
versa historically Specialists from the
haunton have come and done Outreach work
within within within ships and indeed at
the Ellen Badger at the Ellen Badger
hospital I could say that from from
first-hand experience I hope that sort
of uh helps to clarify that to some
degree thank you
thank you very much for a good debate
I also have experienced personal
experience of a community hospital and
the value that it has in that
um it also used to have its own
community hospital
and my husband was one of the people
that went there from the rehabilitation
hospital in in Leamington and I I know
only too well how valued that was and
how much appreciated it was
um to him and myself
um one question that I want would like
the osc to raise when they see uh the
icbcb is about
um people that will work with people in
their homes social care workers or or
support workers in homes given that
there is a bit of a crisis of
recruitment for particular for people to
work in that area I'm just wondering how
well situated they are with recruitment
for those particular posts in in this
area it might be something that you
might want to ask again it's probably a
County council issue but they they must
be aware of what the recruitment is and
the retention is so that might be
something you might want to ask
I now the recommendation is that
there'll be a a change to the
to the notice of motion uh has outlined
on or on sorry not the most noted
emotion but to the options available to
the cabinet and
um what the just to repeat the council
resolves for the leader and portfolio
holder to continue to write to mauritia
County Council Swift and the NHS
Coventry and workshop integrated care
board and obviously we're having them at
the osc to Raise This council's concerns
preferred policy and that the council
supports the public consultation
exercise on the recommendations as
requested by the county council's adult
social Care and housing health
let me just see what the acronym
actually
responds to it's the adult social care
and health overview and scrutiny
committee it's got a very long acronym I
think perhaps we ought to recommend that
that they shouldn't but
just a bit of line and then the
um other option the to revisit the
second recommendation remains as written
so are we I'm going to move that one
have we got anybody that was second that
yeah Council culture and oh we agreed
agreed thank you very much indeed and
can I thank everybody who's come forward
today uh to put the case it has been a
very very interesting and very very uh
heartening and enlightening debate and I
think this recommend this shows just how
much we can do by working together in
this way thank you
it's also remind councilors that that
will be a recommendation to Council in
response yes recommendation to council
and this we'll have the debate again at
Council and I hope um that the council
will take on board what was said to hear
today
moving forward then we've got a capital
budget monitoring period one report and
this is counselor Curtis
thank you leader um
I'd like to thank Nicola Reynolds for
preparing the report and dependencies
it says the report provides cabinet with
details of the capital budget monitoring
for period one to four so first of April
to the 31st of July
um I'll just take a make a few brief
comments and happy to take questions
um
slippage I addressed slippage in cabinet
on 3rd of July and there is further
minor movement detailed in appendix one
um number one leavesham place
we have been successful in securing
number one uh purchased for a cost of
484 000 pounds this has been met by 382
247 pounds
um from the capital program from the
sale of council garages and the the
balance of 130 000 pounds comes from
revenue contribution to capital
expenditure
when number one Asian place comes online
and look forward to getting a time scale
for that there will be annual revenue
Savings of about 105 000 pounds as we
will no longer be providing so much bed
and breakfast accommodation so over
eight to ten years the purchase and
conversion costs will have been repaid
and District Council will retain a
valuable Capital asset so I think this
represents excellent value for money and
demonstrates this administration's
commitment to managing our residence
council tax in the most cost efficient
manner it's a spa smart investment
rather than spending if you like
um refuse vehicles
as members will be aware the refuse
collection service is a joint contract
covering both Stratford and Warwick
District councils
the lowest cost tender received was one
where the councils funded the purchase
of refused vehicles
Warwick agreed to finance the initial
expenditure to purchase all vehicles
both Stratford and Warwick and did so by
using internally held funds rather than
taking out a loan at a time when
interest rates were high
Warwick is now in a position where they
need to use a loan to cover this
expenditure
SDC however has the ability to
internally Finance our vehicles without
the need to borrow
So to avoid unnecessary financing costs
SDC has purchased the refuse vehicles
from Warwick this was always an option
and the capital program contained the
agreed funding to do so
Stratford district will continue to
finance these vehicles from internal
funds at such times that a loan is
required and this will then hopefully be
at a rate lower than we see currently
so the report comes with recommendations
that the position on capital expenditure
and income for period one to four 2023
is received and any issues identified
for further and consideration be
addressed by a further report to the
cabinet or from myself as portfolio
holder
um
I will just mention if I may briefly
um I had an email yesterday from the
chair of ovary and scrutiny is clearly
working overtime just suggesting that
there may be ways in the in which these
reports could be presented with perhaps
greater Clarity and that's something I
will take up with Section 151 officer
Richard bowl at our next weekly meeting
on Thursday so thank you for that
councilor cromp
anybody else want to make any comments
particularly on that item
and councilor Curtis are you moving that
then I will move that yes thank you and
anybody that seconded that that I'm
happy to second that
are we agreed
thank you
moving on then to the next item which is
the
Revenue budget monitoring item which
again is councilor Curtis I do have a
couple of questions if you don't mind
canceling characters but would you like
to present it first thank you
yes again I'd like to thank Jessica ale
for her for providing this report
to update the council's revenue
expenditure and income as a period 4
31st to 23 with an estimated net outturn
position for each service 23 24.
um
brief comments and yes and some
questions section two three just a brief
comment on these write-offs
um Mr Marla shows me that these
write-offs are within the expected
parameters and are primarily the result
of personal bankruptcy or moving on
residents moving on leading leaving no
forward address if residents do return
however efforts are made to chase any
outstanding debts as is required by the
council's Constitution
um 3.13
um the uh rating revaluation increased
business rates for Elizabeth house
um this we're still appearing against
that increased business rate
off street parking the off street
parking revenues primarily have been
affected by poor weather at Key times
which is even with this Administration
it is beyond the control of the level of
Democrats to control the weather
unfortunately
um so that is something that obviously
we will need to monitor that carefully
going forward four one one
um council tax reduction Administration
unfavorable variation of 105 000.
um Mr Brown will give further detail if
you request but essentially this has
been due to an unexpected and unforeseen
reduction in a particular central
government grant
um four one three uh recruitment costs
um rich and I'd spoken about this about
recruitment costs and we agree that a
very effective way of reducing future
recruitment costs is better staff
retention
and offering CPD continual professional
development opportunities to staff are
an excellent way of increasing staff
retention enhancing staff skills
giving better service to Residents and
improving the perception that the
district council values staff
so we hope to address this during the
budget setting process of seeing how we
can provide additional
additional CPD opportunities
um so the recommendation for cabinet is
the actual net variants of period four
isolated Revenue outturn 2324 be
received
any further issues identified for
consideration by a further report to
cabinet for myself and that the
write-offs contained in two three which
I've addressed have are noted thank you
thank you leader
um from chairman of overview and
scrutiny as I was kindly mentioned by
cancer Curtis I just thought I'll come
in briefly I've got the points yet the
recruitment retention uh that is
certainly sensible that's something I've
always believed in and we've raised at
Urban scrutiny before
and sometimes
the benefits of retaining staff that
experience and knowledge is still there
and and when and as Mrs Burke says we'll
bring graduate trainees into to benefit
from that experience so I think that's
fine and reasonable
um
a couple of points of concern uh
interests rights will be starting to
fall I know we've got significant levels
of balances at the moment and some of
which we're holding on behalf of them
and will have to be repaid
and that is to some extent and it did to
the previous administration as well in
22 23 prop up the account so with that
underlining propping up potentially
being removed
um we need to make sure that the
accounting income is is recovered and
came before so
um whilst you can say there will be
um the inflation won't be so high in the
contracts to counteract that but I still
think there's some propping up of
um of of the budget by by the income and
the balances that we've got and thirdly
um I also thought the sun shined on the
liberal Democrats councilor Curtis
so regarding North Street Parking I'm
disappointed that the income has fallen
uh one point is that we would like to
mention is that we're making sure
obviously we're you're bringing in the
parking permit and we've not taken our
Eye Off the Ball concentrating on that
when there's potentially uh our our
things being done to chime boost income
will maintain it I think is it
particularly around season tickets
which I believe have not got back to
pre-covered levels uh I don't know
whether
um
this is a officer Lewis will be able to
come or not that about the season
tickets not being previous levels but I
think we just need to keep an eye on the
ball on that one as well so uh points of
concerns but the points about
recruitment retention are really
accurate and really well I might say
thank you
and on my question I just wondered
whether
um somebody was not an accountant I was
just going through the figures are now
out tried trying to understand the there
is an unfavorable out turn for the year
and overspend of 597 500 when I was
going through it's a paraphor gives the
out uh breakdown for the turn and I
looked at 4.1.4
um and it showed that there's an
interest income of an extra
600 due to increased interest rates
um uh but the first four months alone
show an extra 308
870. I think probably appendix 2 shows
it best
um I'm just wondering is the with the
interest
um and the the
um remaining will there be extra over
the coming year which would wipe out
that deficit for the year of 597 500
um I'm not I'm just struggling to
understand exactly how we you know come
to the the the match those figures
because I I it looks to me as if with
the interest rates we were actually
probably going to be able to cover the
597 500 uh over the year is that going
to be the case
I've been having whispering in my ear as
you can imagine so the 377 000 pounds on
204 page 214 I'm being told that that is
a prudent outcome
obviously I think with the volatility of
interest rates it is very difficult to
predict it may well be that if interest
rates stay
at a relatively high level then there
will be an improvement on that position
but I think at the moment I'm being told
that that's a prudent outcome and we
shouldn't necessarily rely on that would
that be a reasonable oh so you could
sorry I'd say you could rely on that
outcome I wouldn't want to rely on
anything higher than that through at
this stage
good
there is a possibility that if interest
rates rise that you know we could be in
a better position than it seems likely
at the moment certainly yes and I think
that probably also addresses one of the
points that Council of crump was making
as well I hope
yeah I think the point was that because
of volatility
um and obviously as an account index
accountant and like Mr Paul
um we like certainty don't we and
prudence and to rely on things that
could potentially volatile might not be
the best course of action especially so
early in the in the year
Mr Borough do you answer that please
yeah just to address councilor crunt's
uh initial query the medium term
Financial strategy doesn't rely on
long-term interest receipts from
Investments we recognize the current
Financial year that sort of tails off
into the next financial year over the
medium term Financial strategy we don't
rely on large sums of Interest receipts
to proper accounts attacks uh there is a
general feeling now that interest rates
won't drop back to where they were
previously and that will be reviewed
during the next budget setting process
thank you very much that that's it you
know I just kind of was looking through
it and I needed that clarify so thank
you very much indeed for that that's
appreciated
um now are you going to move that record
yes I'd like to propose those
recommendations thank you and I'm happy
to second that after having that
question answered so thank you very much
indeed are we all agreed agreed thank
you moving on then to the member
development working group and this is
councilor guest
sorry I was pressing the wrong button
um right
um
I'm asking a cabinet to agree the uh
six-month working program for the member
development working group I just wanted
to thank officers for the training
program
um that we've had I think we can all
agree it's very comprehensive a lot of
information
um just as a general comment as a group
we are looking to have more online
training for members and more recorded
training where possible for members uh
obviously we appreciate lots of people
have other jobs and other commitments to
try and make that a bit easier for
people
of any members of the cabinet got any
questions to ask of that one
no in which case are you prepared to
move that one Council case yes yes and
um secondary counselor capture
okay agreed agree thank you very much
indeed
and the next is uh Part F other matters
urgent business I've not been notified
of any urgent business is there any the
chief executive got any items no and
then the there was exclusion of the
public but but no questions have been
raised that would um
oh yeah sorry
yeah
I've missed a page the pages that um the
issues arising from overview and
scrutiny committee how could I possibly
Overlook that one I know what it was you
think you'll keep that
just very briefly um one last thing
we'll discussed
um and we talked about communication we
talk about the view uh and we felt that
um
there needs to be some review and update
on the website it was particularly
pertinent about climate change pan and I
know Council climate transaction plan
Keithley had done some work in his life
and he raised some points that it hadn't
been updated since I think it was
October 21.
and obviously and I think the fact that
was I'm sure you said four to six pages
uh on it on Mr perks or confirm that was
the right number and it seemed to be
quite unwieldy
so they've um what we felt from over in
scrutiny is one
um some item to do with reviewing the
output uh on the website well it's
timely well it's needed whether it's up
to date where it's accurate
because we thought we'd rather have this
information there that was accurate and
easy to use the more information wasn't
necessarily up to date but again there
were potential resource implications of
doing that
um we felt that
um at one stage the climate change
action plan should be we would ask the
cabinet to schedule updates on the
climate transaction panel for each
climate change panel meeting but post
needs enough this is going to offer so
we thought if they could do that twice a
year rather than rather than every
meeting but it would also be sensible to
have details of climate change
expenditure produced at each meeting
just to see what's going on and I think
in in the past cancer curses has raised
issues regarding spending of The the
Reserve is that right against Curtis
I think I may have mentioned that
occasionally good man I'm glad we're
doing well
um and then there was also to do with
external Partners to do with Roxy Royal
Housing Association the capital Planet
which we'll be bringing back uh and
we've also still working on the task and
finish on housing associations uh which
has got a lot of input from members uh
and is working well under the guys and
chairmanship of against the Wally
Huggins there so
and supported by offices especially in
that they're sorry when you restart that
so yeah that's the update from opening
scrutiny thank you thank you I
understand that um and now again we'll
get a briefing on this one but just to
be sure but I understand that the the
action plan is under uh looking being
re-looked out to to you know refresh
that and bring it up to date on the on
the website but I will take that on
board I understand that there is a
National Organization and a climate
change emergency UK I believe has been
doing a scorecard on previous action
plans and in some ways it actually is is
useful for them to be able to see the
one that was already in place and then
we can look at that um what comments
they're making in order to be able to
update our one accordingly to make sure
that we're taking on board any feedback
from that organization
um so I think that was all the issues
arising from the organ scrutiny
committee
um we've got cabinet committees there
was none to report on the next item is
on block items and that covers the
cabinet work program the climate change
panel and the member development working
group
um if anybody's got any items to raise
if not I will move those on block
happy for that to be agreed agreed okay
thank you
and the Part F was the other matters
which I had addressed earlier urgent
business I'm not aware of that there is
urgent any urgent business and we've got
no reason to go into exempt area because
no questions have been raised I believe
I'm correct on that one okay
so
um
that then brings an end to this cabinet
meeting thank you